i'm here to talk to you about
the economic invisibility of nature the
bad news is that
mother nature's back office isn't quite
working yet so those invoices don't get
issued
but we need to do something about this
problem i
began my life as as a markets
professional and
continued to take an interest but most
of my recent effort has been looking at
the value of what comes to human beings
from nature
and which doesn't get priced by markets
a project called teeb was started in
and it was launched by a group of
environment ministers of the g8 plus
five
and their basic inspiration was a stern
review of lord stern
they asked themselves the question if
economics could make such a convincing
case for early action on climate change
well why can't the same be done for
conservation why can't an equivalent
case be made
for nature and the answer is yeah it can
but it's not that straightforward
biodiversity the living fabric of this
planet is not a gas
it exists in many layers ecosystems
species and genes
across many scales international
national local community
and doing for nature what lord stern and
esteem did for climate
is not that easy and yet we began we
began the project with an interim report
which quickly pulled together a lot of
information that had been collected on
the subject
by many many researchers and amongst
our compiled results was the startling
revelation that in fact we were losing
natural capital
the benefits that flow from nature to us
we were losing it at an extraordinary
rate
in fact of the order of two to four
trillion dollars worth of natural
capital
uh this came out in 2008 which was of
course around the time that the banking
crisis had
shown that we had lost financial capital
of the order of
two and a half trillion dollars so this
was comparable in size to that kind of
loss
we then have gone on since to present
for international community for
governments for local governments and
for businesses and for people for you
and me
a whole slew of reports which were
presented at the un last year
which address the economic invisibility
of nature and describe what can be done
to solve it what is this about
a picture that you're familiar with the
amazon rainforest
it's a massive store of carbon it's an
amazing store of biodiversity but what
people don't really know is it's also
it's a rain factory because the
northeastern trade winds as they go
over the amazonas effectively gather the
water vapor
something like 20 billion tons per day
of water vapor is
sucked up by the northeastern trade
winds and eventually
precipitates in the form of rain across
the la plata basin
this rainfall cycle this rainfall
factory effectively feeds an
agricultural economy
of the order of 240 billion dollars
worth in latin america
but the question arises okay so how much
do uruguay paraguay argentina and indeed
the state of mata grosso and brazil
pay for that vital input to that economy
to the state of amazonas which produces
that rainfall
and the answer is sinch exactly zero
that's the economic invisibility of
nature that can't keep going on because
economic incentives and disincentives
are very powerful economics has become
the currency of policy
and unless we address this invisibility
we are going to get the results that we
are seeing which is a gradual
degradation and loss of this valuable
natural asset
it's not just about the amazon us or
indeed about rainforest no matter what
level you look at whether it's at the
ecosystem level or at the species level
or the genetic level
we see the same problem again and again
so
rainfall cycle and water regulation by
rainforest at an ecosystem level
at the species level it's been estimated
that insect-based pollination bees
pollinating
fruit and so on is something like 190
billion dollars worth
that's something like an eight percent
of the total agricultural
output globally completely passes below
the radar screen
when did a bee actually ever give you an
invoice
or for that matter if you look at the
genetic level 60
of medicines were prospective were found
first as molecules
in a rainforest or a reef once again
most of that doesn't get paid
and that brings me to another aspect of
this which is to whom should this get
paid
that genetic material probably belonged
if it could belong to anyone to a local
community of poor people who
parted with the knowledge that helped
the researchers to find the molecule
which then became the medicine
they were the ones that didn't get paid
and if you look at the species level
you saw about fish today the depletion
of ocean fisheries is so significant
that effectively it is affecting the
ability of the poor the artisanal
fissure folk
and those who fish for their own
livelihoods to feed their families
something like a billion people depend
on fish the quantity of fish in the
oceans
a billion people depend on fish for
their main source for animal protein and
at this rate at which we are losing fish
it is a human problem of enormous
dimensions
a health problem of a kind that we
haven't seen before
and finally at the ecosystem level
whether it's flood prevention or drought
control provided by the forest
or whether it is the ability of poor
farmers to go out
and gather leaf litter for their cattle
and goats so whether it's the ability of
their wives to go in and collect fuel
wood from the forest
it is actually the poor who depend most
on these ecosystem services
we did estimates in our in our study
that for countries like brazil india and
indonesia
even though ecosystem services these
benefits that flow from natures to
humanity for free
they're not very big in percentage terms
of gdp two four eight ten fifteen
percent
but in these countries if we measure how
much they're worth to the poor
the answers are more like forty five
percent seventy five percent
ninety percent that's the difference
because these are important
benefits for the poor and you can't
really have
a proper model for development if at the
same time
you are destroying or allowing the
degradation of the very asset the most
important asset which is your
development asset
that is ecological infrastructure how
bad can things get
well here's a picture of something
called the mean species abundance
it's basically a measure of how many
tigers toads ticks or whatever on
average
of biomass of various species around the
green
represents the percentage if it's dark
green it's like
80 to 100 percent if it's yellow it's 40
to 60 percent and these are percentages
versus the original
state so to speak the pre-industrial
area 1750.
now i'm going to show you how business
as usual will affect this
and just watch the change in colors in
india china
europe sub-saharan africa as we move on
and consume global biomass at a rate
which is actually
not going to be able to sustain us see
that again
the only places that remain green and
that's not good news is in fact
places like the gobi desert like the
tundra and like sahara
that doesn't help because there were
very few species and volume of biomass
there in the first place
this is the challenge the reason this is
happening
boils down in my mind to one basic
problem which is our inability to
perceive the difference
between public benefits and private
profits
we tend to constantly ignore public
wealth simply because it is in the
common wealth it's it's common goods
and here's an example from thailand
where we found that because
the value of a mangrove is not that much
it's about 600
over the life of nine years that this
has been measured compared to its value
as a shrimp farm which is more like nine
thousand six hundred dollars
there has been a gradual trend to
deplete the mangroves and convert them
to shrimp farms but of course
if you look at what exactly those
profits are
almost 8 000 of those dollars are in
fact subsidies
so you compare the two sides of the coin
and you find that it's more like 1200
versus 600 that's not that hot but on
the other hand
if you start measuring how much would it
actually cost to restore
the land of the shrimp farm back to
productive use
once salt deposition and chemical
deposition has actually had its effects
that answer is more like twelve thousand
dollars of cost and
if you see the benefits of the mangrove
in terms of the storm protection and
cyclone protection that you get
and in terms of the fisheries the nurse
fish nurseries that provide fish for the
poor
that answer is more like eleven thousand
dollars so now
look at the different lens if you look
at the lens of public wealth
as against the lens of private profits
you get a completely different answer
which is
clearly conservation makes more sense
and not destruction
so is this just a story from south
thailand sorry this is a global story
and here's what the same calculation
looks like which was done recently
and well i see recently over the last 10
years by a group called truecast
and they calculated for the top 3000
corporations what are the externalities
in other words what are the costs of
doing business as usual this is not
illegal stuff this is basically
business as usual which causes
climate-changing emissions which have an
economic cost
it causes pollutants being issued which
have an economic cost health costs
and so on use of fresh water if you
drill
water to make coke near a village farm
that's not illegal but yes it costs the
community
can we stop this and how i think the
first point to make is that we need to
recognize natural capital
basically the stuff of life is natural
capital and we need to recognize that
and build that into our systems
when we measure gdp as a measure of
economic performance at the national
level we don't include our biggest asset
at the country level
when we measure corporate performances
we don't include our impacts on nature
and on what our business costs society
that has to stop in fact this was what
really inspired my
interest in this space i began a project
way back called the green accounting
project
that was in the in early 2000 when india
was going gungo about
gdp growth as the means forward looking
at china with its stellar growth of
eight nine ten percent
and wondering why can't we do the same
and a few friends of mine and i decided
this doesn't make sense this is going to
create
more costs to society and more losses so
we decided to do a massive set of
calculations
and started producing green accounts for
india and its states that's how
my interest began and went to the team
project calculating this at the national
level is one thing and it has begun
and the world bank has acknowledged this
and they've started a project called
waves wealth accounting and valuation of
ecosystem services
but calculating this at the next level
that means that the sec at the business
sector level is important and actually
we've done this
with the t project we've done this for a
very difficult case
which was for deforestation in china
this is important
because in china in 1997 the yellow
river actually went dry for nine months
causing severe loss of agricultural
output and pain and loss to society
just a year later the yangtze flooded
causing something like 5 500 deaths
so clearly there was a problem with
deforestation it was associated largely
with the construction industry
and the chinese government responded
sensibly and placed a ban on felling
a retrospective on 40 years shows that
if we had accounted for these costs the
costs of loss of
topsoil the cost of loss of waterways
the lost productivity the loss to local
communities as a result of all these
factors desertification and so on
those costs are almost twice as much as
the market price of timber so in fact
the price of timber in the beijing
marketplace ought to have been three
times what it was
had it reflected the true pain and the
cost to the society within china
of course after the event one can be
wise the way to do this is to do it on a
company basis
to take leadership forward and to do it
for as many important sectors which have
a cost
and to disclose these answers someone
wants to ask me
who is better or worse is it unilever or
is it png when it comes to their impact
on rainforests in indonesia and i
couldn't answer because neither of these
companies good that they are
and professional though they are do not
calculate or disclose their
externalities
but if we look at companies like puma
yukon sites their ceo and chairman
once challenged me at a function saying
that he's going to implement my project
before i finish it
well i think we kind of did it at the
same time but he's done it he's
basically worked out the cost to puma
puma has 2.7 billion dollars of turnover
300 million dollars of profits 200
million dollars after tax
94 million dollars of externalities cost
to business now that's not a happy
situation for them but they have the
confidence and the courage to come
forward and say
here's what we are measuring we are
measuring it because we know that you
cannot manage what you do not measure
that's an example i think for us to look
at and for us to draw comfort from
if more companies did this and if more
sectors engage this as sectors
you could have analysts business
analysts and you could have people like
us and consumers and ngos
actually look and compare the social
performance of companies today we can't
yet do that
but i think the path is laid out this
can be done and i'm delighted that the
institute of chartered accountants in
the uk has already set up a coalition
to do this an international coalition
the other
favorite if you like solution for me is
the creation of green carbon markets and
by the way these are my favorites
externalities calculation and green
carbon markets team has
more than a dozen separate groups of
solutions including
protected area evaluation and payments
for ecosystem services and eco
certification and you name it but these
are the favorites
what's green carbon today what we have
is basically a brown carbon marketplace
it's about energy emissions
the european union ets is the main
marketplace it's not doing too well
we've over issued
a bit like inflation you over issue
currency you get what you see
declining prices but that's all about
energy
and industry but what we are missing out
is also some other emissions like black
carbon that is soot
what we are also missing is blue carbon
which by the way is the largest store of
carbon more than 55 percent
thankfully the flux in other words the
flow of emissions from the ocean
to the atmosphere and vice versa is more
or less balanced
in fact what's being absorbed is
something like 25 percent of our
emissions
which then leads to acidification or
lower alkalinity in oceans
more of that in a minute and finally
there's deforestation
and there's emission of methane from
agriculture
green carbon which is the deforestation
and agricultural emissions
and blue carbon together comprise 25
percent of our emissions
we have the means already in our hands
through a structure
through a mechanism called red plus a
scheme for the reduced emissions from
deforestation and forest degradation
and already norway has contributed a
billion dollars each towards indonesia
and brazil to implement
this red plus scheme so we actually have
some movement forward but the thing is
to do a lot more of that
will this solve the problem will
economics solve everything
well i'm afraid not there is an area
that is
the oceans coral reefs as you can see
they cut across the entire globe all the
way from micronesia
across indonesia malaysia india
madagascar
and to the west of the caribbean these
red dots these red areas basically
provide the food and livelihood for more
than half a billion people
so that's almost an eighth of society
and the sad thing is that as these coral
reefs are lost and scientists tell us
that
any level of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere above 350 past per million
is too dangerous for the survival of
these reefs we are not only risking the
extinction of the entire coral species
the warm water corals we're not only
risking
a fourth of all fish species which are
in the oceans but we are risking the
very lives and livelihoods
of more than 500 million people who live
in the developing world in poor
countries so in selecting targets of 450
parts per million and selecting two
degrees at the
climate negotiations what we have done
is we've made an ethical choice
we've actually kind of made an ethical
choice in society
to not have coral reefs well
what i will say to you in parting is
that we may have done that let's think
about it and what it means but please
let's not do more of that
because mother nature only has that much
in ecological
infrastructure and that much natural
capital i don't think we can afford too
much
of such ethical choices thank you
you